well cuz I got punched in the face by a
bouncer cuz I was the same guy I'd be
mouthy right one got bounced it was Vine
days this guy goes hey can I talk to you
outside I go oh you seen the
video oh you don't you want to be lowkey
you want to take a photo respect keep a
low key keep it low key meanwhile I'm
[__] out four Cosmos my eyes are
looking like the new Twitter logo I'm
just over here pulled me outside new
Twitter logo is good and then thank you
so much and then so he like uh he like
puts me outside and goes to CL like slam
the door and I grab the door and then he
flinches and I go what this dude is like
an old s State like linebacker that's
why I went to school like massive dude
he goes what I said what he flinches and
then he just clocks me right in the eye
and I'm just bleeding just and I'm
walking home and then it gets real white
I call the bar nobody answers and I left
probably the longest voicemail in the
history you didn't know
thisa voice I'm walking home like you
know [__] I'm a film major I just go
full have you seen I don't need a 23 and
me that is I'm 100% white after doing
that you SE FIA um but that thank God
that bar closed because if they were
still open I'm sure somehow they could
get in their like their source and see
if they still have that but the next day
I was like oh I deserve that I deserve
that I didn't I know the story but I
didn't hear the voicemail part it was
like walk home so I was just yapping do
you know what you said leading up to the
punch in the face like what got him
upset so he I got the door and then I
just said what and I think what no I
mean before when he's like yo let's go
outside why you got to get I think I was
probably like why why why no I'm good
I'm good I'm not drk why did you want to
oh you're just too drunk and that's why
he just saw me like being he's just
trying to get you he's not trying to
kick my dick was out and I was peeing on
the floor but I don't know what I was
doing I I don't know I think I in my
head I I didn't think I was that drunk
that's I was like why why why why are we
going outside why we going outside but
he's kind of just like bulldozing me a
little bit into a corner and then the
door happened and have you been pun in
the face a go no shockingly not really
shockingly not no wow have you of course
yeah there you go for what a random
Tuesday I used to fight a lot when I was
younger why well not a lot 11 fights
that's a lot 11 fights that's what I'm
saying that's a lot oh I didn't know L
For What just like I grew up in not the
best neighborhood just that type of
stupid [__] okay yeah damn all right
seven and four yeah yeah I was winning
seven and four that's great yeah no Dad
yeah half half
halfway I don't have a dad either good
good oh yeah know I had to say Jesus
Christ yeah oh yeah that sounded wild
that's why I
said to get a 12 fight out of right now
why my
dad circumcised
circumcised boys we boys see I said he
was Jewish dog come on now circumcised
circumcised yeah of course good also
guys I'm not going to waste time talking
supports with these two because they
don't know nothing about it so if you
didn't know I had been on an
unbelievable cold streak on price picks
we're going to keep it going you know
the plan you pick the exact opposite of
what I suggest and that's going to make
you money also you sign up at price.com
and use the promo code Schultz they will
match your initial deposit up to $100 so
if you invest a 100 you deposit 100 you
get 100 for free this uh you really
can't lose unless you're me and then you
find a way to lose every week but that's
how you win just pick the opposite of me